el 9 de julio de 2018 fue la investidura
del presidente erdogan Y solo hubo un
invitado latinoamericano fue Venezuela
con su presidente Nicolás Maduro
relaciones que han ido creciendo y están
actualmente en su momento cumbre de
hecho a principios de 2023 el canciller
venezolano Iván Hill dijo que las
relaciones están en su máximo nivel en
este momento el intercambio comercial se
sitúa alrededor de los mil millones de
dólares con acuerdos en 40 áreas
especialmente destacable es el vínculo
en cuestiones del Oro tras las sanciones
Venezuela dejó de refinar oro en Suiza y
pasó a Turquía una alternativa económica
al bloqueo de su petróleo en la cuestión
política Cabe destacar que erdogan no
reconoció a Juan guaidó como presidente
interino de Venezuela y el pasado año
tras la invasión de Rusia Ucrania el
canciller aseguró que el mundo entero
necesita el petróleo y el gas natural de
Venezuela
y Luis estos han sido los lazos entre
erdogan y maduro no pero qué relación
Podría tener kilishroglu con maduros si
llega eventualmente a ganar la
presidencia recordemos Rosa que
kilisarolú es proclive a occidente y
querría distanciarse de Vladimir Putin
uno de los socios de Venezuela sin
embargo rebuscando en la hemeroteca nos
hemos encontrado con el siguiente tuit
creemos firmemente que Venezuela seguirá
ascendiendo y desarrollándose a partir
del camino abierto por Chávez
estas fueron sus palabras tras la muerte
de Chávez por lo que alejarse de las
posturas de erdogan no implicaría que
pudiera perder el camino emprendido en
las relaciones entre Turquía y Venezuela
sin embargo en plena campaña la semana
pasada hubo un escándalo el ministro de
agricultura de Turquía se fue de visita
a Venezuela y que les daré dijo que en
Turquía tienen muy buena agricultura y
que eso no es necesario y dejó una
pregunta al aire Rosa van a por
Venezuela van a Venezuela por otra razón
ellos lo saben bien eso fue lo que dijo
que mal